[Music]
things that we take for granted walk
around to see it every day
difficult to speak
[Music]
new fob Bell we will rebuild not to Dan
because that's what the French expect
and because it is what our history
deserves
[Music]
it's literally the heart of Paris we are
I was born and raised here at the scene
is building all my life it's part of my
history my culture its France that's
been touched
France is burning I feel like Paris it's
all Paris is crying now not just to me
an icon of Paris and it's just shocking
and now it's all change for all time
[Music]
[Music]
for the people of France
these images are heartbreaking this
iconic landmark so dominant on the Paris
skyline is miraculously still standing
but much of it now reduced to a
burnt-out shell for more than eight
centuries in Ultra Dom survived
revolutions and world wars it will be
rebuilt but France will have to be
patient experts believe it will be at
least a decade before it's restore to
its former glory when I so you know the
flames red blood orange flames coming
out of the roof and the upper window
rose windows it was very shocking a lot
of people went here somewhere silently
praying some others sigh you know
quietly singing some Catholic songs and
but people weren't shocked because it's
history the first signs that something
terrible was unfolding came early
evening the cathedral below mass was
under way
[Music]
worshipers completely oblivious to the
blaze developing above them
[Music]
outside their fellow Parisians could see
much more clearly the magnitude of what
was developing the billowing smoke
visible right across the French capital
confined it first
to just one end of the building within
the hour the blaze had engulfed the
entire roof it's ancient oak beams
fueling the flames as horrified locals
and thousands of tourists watched in
disbelief
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody's just shocked I think they're
just you know trying to to have this
kind of last moment with with no to them
oh boy we saw the roof collapse we're
shocked
it's 850 years of history it really
hurts
it was sad arguably the cathedrals most
recognizable feature its needle-like
spire stood up to the inferno for longer
than many had expected but with its
wooden supports eaten away by the flames
it was only a matter of time before the
inevitable
[Music]
firefighters from all over Paris fought
to control this blaze their own video
giving a close-up perspective of the
monumental challenge they faced
with ancient wooden Timbers already
collapsing around them there was for
several hours real concern much of the
stone fabric of this building would
follow
there's still aerial image taken at the
height of the blaze showed an almost
total collapse of the roof space but a
testament to the skills of the medieval
craftsmen who built her somehow the bulk
of the stonework has survived
as the French presidents arrived to
inspect the efforts of the emergency
services it was already becoming clear
that they would be able to save the mean
structure Beth yonder we will rebuild
this Cathedral together and it is
undoubtedly part of the French destiny
and a project for the years to come but
I am committed to it a national
fundraiser will be launched and well
beyond our borders we will appeal to the
greatest talents and many people will
come and contribute to it and we will
rebuild we will rebuild not trade on
because that's what the French expect
and because it is what our history
deserves because it's our underlying
destiny asakusa's cannot least welcome
it as a full investigation gets underway
the working theory is that this blaze
was accidental construction workers had
been involved in a multi-million euro
restoration of notre-dame and
scaffolding covered parts of the roof
where the fire started in recent days
many of the copper statues representing
the 12 apostles were dismantled and
removed by crane and insight thanks to
the bravery of firefighters many of the
priceless arts and other treasures were
also saved some have been damaged but
it's hoped many can be restored home a
cab for sickle is a Libby on occasion
mark Abu teamwork was carried out to
secure the most precious Goods notably
the crown of thorns and the tunic of San
Louie which is safe in the city who the
rest of the treasures will be put in
safety in the loop from today or
tomorrow as quickly as possible
regarding the paintings the big
paintings the works of not chewed on
these can be taken out of nacho Dom
probably as soon as Friday morning at
the moment there is no damage linked to
the fire but damage linked to the smoke
so we will transport them safely to
storage in the Louvre where they will be
dehumidified and protected conserved and
restored
[Music]
not Rodham is one of France's most
popular tourist destinations steeped in
history and immortalized in literature
and on film with movies like The
Hunchback of Notre Dom Napoleon
Bonaparte was crowned emperor at Notre
Dame in 1804 in 1909 Joan of Arc who'd
helped France battle the English and was
burnt at the stake centuries earlier was
beatified in the cathedral no column is
like the Church of the nation all the
big events in French history taken place
here when the king as a victory there
was a celebration in not Verdana year
napoleon was crowned year's General de
Gaulle's regret is the librarian after
the Second World War
it's like just the Church of the French
nation also for non-believers it's a
very important place around the globe
world leaders have issued messages of
sadness and support for the French
people in the UK the Queen whose own
castle in Windsor was badly damaged by
fire in 1992 said her prayers were with
France as she praised the work of fire
crews
at times of deep national trauma
symbolism can be all-important
and many have seized on the poignancy of
these images a golden crucifix still
standing on the mean altar somehow
surviving the inferno I was very struck
by a photograph we saw there at the far
end of a devastated Cathedral there was
a cross there still standing and when
you think in these days were celebrating
Holy Week was celebrating the death on a
cross and the resurrection of Jesus then
we can see in that image yes the
destruction of a large part of a
Cathedral but the promise of the
Resurrection as well with the far
knowledge and investigations well
underway attention is now turning to the
task ahead in trying to restore this
world-famous cathedral some of France's
business leaders are already coming
forward with offers of many millions of
euros this most spectacular of landmarks
has suffered adversity and damage over
the years and somehow survived it will
take time and huge effort but the people
of France have little doubt not radom
will rise again to take its place the
heart of their nation